French Riot police in the Paris suburb
of Norterra trying to contain a
situation that's become so violent the
police deployed an armored vehicle in a
residential neighborhood
protesters built barricades as anger
continues to boil after a police officer
shot dead 17-year-old Niel on Tuesday in
another suburb demonstrators torched a
swimming pool being built for next
year's Olympics while in central Paris
some people looted shops in the morning
residents in Norterra took stock this
restaurant owner says Nile's killing was
a tragedy but violence isn't the answer
all this damage won't bring a solution
we have to find Democratic responses we
have to respect the law you can't just
create chaos who ends up suffering it's
the poorest it's us working people the
women at this estate agent have been
trying to clean up there is a lot of
broken glass construction workers are
boarding up the ground floor of this
building it was completely burnt in the
unrest and the restaurant over there has
also been tidying up a lot of people are
very concerned in this area about what
the coming nights will be thing
Michael's a teacher who's lived in
Norterra for nearly 40 years he says
Nile's death has inflamed a deep-rooted
problems
unemployment inflation life's everyday
struggles It All Leads to situations
like this if there was Full Employment
here if young people could go to school
instead of school shutting we'd have
less problems
French government has aimed Nile's
killing but their calls for calm have
yet to be heeded leaving president
Emmanuel macro under increasing pressure
to end the unrest that some fear could
spiral out of control Natasha Butler Al
Jazeera Monte France
all right let's get the latest now from
Paul